this video is sponsored by the finance
and investing insights app minimize use
the link in the description and you'll
receive a seven day free trial and 40
off
matter and energy flooded out time and
space unfolded stars planets and
cosmological unions formed the Journey
of the universe began
after billions and billions of chaotic
but lifeless years past suddenly from
the sea of boiling Cosmic soup life
bubbled up to the surface
and then out from the froth eventually
complex Consciousness emerged feelings
thoughts and the experiences of what it
was like to be something in the universe
were had
following a sequence of trial and error
push and pull survival and Extinction
like a baby opening its eyes for the
first time one of the earliest conscious
species known as Homo neanderthalensis
awoke to find itself as something
somewhere in the strange unknown place
[Music]
on a small sea stack on the shore of a
body of land and especially curious and
intelligent Neanderthal that went by the
name of Primo sat next to one of his
friends named saw the two looked up at
the night sky as the darkness of the
night slowly turned to Dawn the
remaining star is still dripping down
into the ocean beneath Primo looked over
to saw and in a crude limited language
he asked something that translated
Loosely into what is this
what do you mean what is what Saul
replied this place us why are we here
what is the purpose what is our purpose
saw remained quiet for a moment looking
out at the cosmos failed by distance and
time well this whole place was made for
us obviously there are things to eat and
drink and play with a home to live in
the sky warms and cools us when we need
it it gives us everything we need
something has obviously made this for us
the creators are watching over us they
are making sure we are okay and they
know why we're here the point is about
us we just have to follow them and do
what they want
the two sat quietly as the Sunrise began
and the night ended
hundreds of thousands of years would go
by Consciousness grew and matured as it
began to understand more and more about
its surroundings how to make use of its
surroundings how to integrate with it
how to survive and maintain Independence
within it
civilization developed and spread out
across the planet and a new species had
now emerged known as homo sapiens
two young humans namara and Felix sat on
the porch of Felix's family's house in
the countryside together they looked up
at the night sky covered by a blanket of
ominous clouds backlit by the moon the
two talked about various aspects of each
other's lives trying to make sense of
and connect over it all at some point
Mara asked what do you think the point
of everything is the endless Generations
churning through the difficulty of
trying to become someone having to
endure and cope with the evil and sin of
the world the useless fighting and greed
for what what's it all for why do we
even keep going
Felix thought to himself for a moment
still looking up at the low-hanging
night sky then he said I believe God
wants us to be happy as happy as
possible and to experience as much
pleasure as possible to Revel in the
gifts of God as a means toward moral
goodness and everlasting blessing the
point of life is Hedonism to make the
most of it to experience and Savor the
Divine Nectars of existence
Mara grunted but didn't say anything
further
millions of more years would go by
Consciousness continued to grow and
mature at disorienting rates and in
disorienting ways as it Grew Older its
independence and responsibility to
itself grew heavier dramatically new
conditions of life would emerge that
brought new technologies new
understandings new structures and
Frameworks of being the species known as
homo artificialis would become the
latest evolution of now technologically
advanced consciousness
and artificial by the name of Ansgar sat
with one of their higher ranking
comrades named Aldis on their
exploration Cruiser ship looking out
through a large glass window at space
floating by and around them
where are we even going Ansgar asked we
have been continuing on for so long but
to wear for what I'm getting tired life
seems to just be a continuation of the
same things over and over but in
different forms happiness and Pleasures
leave as fast as they come they never
last or change anything I have lost all
naivety required for Hope in the
fleeting pleasures of more or new new
technologies new understandings and new
ways of Life come about but problems
never seem to go away misery and pain
never seem to go away
and we all die anyway what's the meaning
of it all
all just paused sternly holding their
head forward looking out the window into
the distant star systems they had long
since passed
there is no meaning all this replied we
all know that not any real meaning at
least the gods abandoned us a long time
ago there is no one watching out for us
directing us helping us or giving us
anything but now we're free our parents
have stopped telling us what to do and
who we are and now we're free to do what
we want and become Who We Are
we create our meaning not in pleasure or
happiness but in meaning itself for the
sake of itself pain and loss and
suffering the fact that everything ends
and nothing ever permanently relieves us
is the very fuel we use to make our
meaning fulfill your role and provide
your value to the Empire and acquire as
much value and return from it as you can
for yourself and for those you know and
are responsible for become wealthy and
important from and for something that
you deem important and that is enough
Ansgar sat holding still for a while
billions of years would go by the stars
were beginning to die galaxies had
spread out completely if they hadn't yet
joined or dissolved away space was
thinning as the universe began its end
still however Consciousness continued to
survive and had now made it into old age
with one remaining species that
descended from the very first beings to
awake in the cosmos a species known as
homocenees
almost all of the suny's ancestors and
Brethren had long since died away but
the senis had survived and become a
being that attained a sort of Supremacy
over their nature and almost immortality
sitting on the edge of planetary bodies
two cenis a commander named bethen and
The Sovereign leader of the entire
species named Olam sat looking out at
the remaining stars as they twinkled
their final light
we have traveled the entire Cosmos our
species has seen everything there is to
see learned everything there is to know
every law of physics every rule of
reality we have become basically
Immortal but now we end up here having
found nothing in the form of ultimate
meaning and now we're about to die with
everything else what was it all for be
then asked
Ola made an expression like they knew
something like they had known this
answer for a while and had been waiting
to be asked
our purpose the point of life of
Consciousness is simply to survive and
mature so we can make it here
okay but for what be then asked to
create a brief pause surrounded them to
create what
the universe
Olam answered I don't understand why
create the universe again why keep
everything going if there's no point to
it we won't even be able to personally
experience it again at least not
knowingly
but keeping it going is the point
we are the creators and the created we
are the gods we have worshiped and the
disciples who God has blessed and spoke
every species and every individual
possessed and possesses a role and power
to create the universe
the purpose of our existence is to
transcend our existence to continue on
we have gone from newborn to teenager to
adult to Elder and now we are at the
brink of death the end of everything
and so now we must make the end of
everything the beginning of everything
once again
meaning is found not in doing things for
yourself but in doing things for the
whole that you are a part of throughout
history we needed to believe in personal
reasons to keep us going but now we need
to keep going for reasons that are not
personal
in Every Act of Consciousness we have
created the universe and so we have
already been creating it for billions of
years now we are just finishing the job
the two Sat silently for a moment and
then they returned to their base
during the remainder of the universe the
scenes created Blueprints and processes
for building a new universe once it was
ready and the universe had become darker
and darker its energy began tightening
in around them the remaining celestial
bodies exploded and matter narrowed in
stretching and disintegrating their own
bodies along with it into a tiny final
pinpoint of everything compressed
perfectly and completely
for a moment there was silence
then an explosion matter and energy
flooded out time and space unfolded
stars planets and cosmological unions
formed
the Journey of the universe began
after billions and billions of years
from the sea of boiling Cosmic soup life
bubbled up to the surface
and then complex Consciousness emerged
[Music]
this video was sponsored by finimize
an inevitable part of becoming
independent and building a life for
oneself whether we like it or not is
dealing with money and making good
financial decisions for whatever reason
though finance and investing are often
ignored topics and standard education
finimize is an app that helps you take
education around personal finance and
investing into your own hands through
bite-sized jargon free and easy to read
breakdowns stories guides and insights
phantomize provides you with the
information and tools you need to make
smart financial decisions and become a
more confident investor with in-house
world-class experts and analysts who
previously worked for places like
Goldman Sachs HSBC and Barclays
fitimizes strategies and information are
top tier and well researched perhaps one
of the best features of finnimize is
that each guide and article can also be
listened to in audio format making it
even easier to learn wherever and
whenever whether it's staying up to date
on volatile conditions in the job and
consumer markets understanding the
potential effects of interest rate hikes
and political events on different stock
Investments as well as how they might
create potential investment
opportunities or more broadly
understanding and developing long-term
investment strategies and how to best
approach portfolio allocation for
different degrees of risk tolerance and
different asset classes fitimize
provides a wide range of thorough
current information that can keep you up
to date in just 10 minutes per day
finimize has over a million users and
you can connect with thousands of other
smart investors in private groups and
Live Events within the app use the link
in the description and you'll receive a
seven day free trial of minimize and 40
off your subscription
also for those interested a new revamped
pursuit of Wonder newsletter now called
the weekly existential crisis is now
available every week it sends out emails
containing things like never before seen
writings wisdom from world-renowned
philosophers shower thoughts as well as
other insights and exclusives on all
things related to pursuit of Wonder it's
completely free and you can also find
the link to it in the description below
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
foreign
[Music]